oh everybody in the red jerseys they just
want to get going here they want to get
moving their new head coach Spencer carbury
is now officially an NHL coach pretty cool
really good story we'll get into that as the
night progresses here's Alexander oetkin it
across the line ray everybody's finishing their
checks tonight this is a far different pace and
tone than the game the other night in Pittsburgh
Carson roaring in jar h in the post and he'll L
on Chalk for but yeah oh yeah we had the
chalkboard but then it moved in high-tech
into the dryer oh turnover through the legs
M getting fancy and it doesn't work out that
time it's this Puck spins off the turnover the
misplay and Malin tries to go back through his
legs that's where R asmith sandini he wants
to pass it thinks better of it so he tries
to reload and Malin tries to go through his
legs look I'm I understand what he's doing
here able to go across here's gensel leaves for
rust makes the move rust to the forehand and
it's covered up by Charlie lingren and here's
Emily what do you got Emily yeah just talk to
Kirk Muller assistant with the Cavs that
period they really like their Pace really
like their Puck management you know the pens
are a team that can jump on it shot to score
and get Maring unchecked in the slot and
Pittsburgh scores first to take the one up
lead the face off is one and it's the
oetkin turnover that keeps this Play
Alive Malin right off the faceof circle just
turns around he had three shots in that first
period the pass finds him all alone and
ofgy malin's got his first of the season
never afraid to shoot the puck had a game high
six shots in the open looking for their first
Power Play goal of the Season meric Carlson
on quarterback things and he comes out with
speed here's Carlson it opens up right for him
gets his own rebound as Eric Carlson goes Coast
to Coast lingren had to make one save nearly
two Crosby swinging across here's Carlson with
the step things up now SIDS on his backand
look back for Carlson gel on it there finds
Rael Carlson cross from Marin it's in es skates
now settles it down side of it at one touch and
in for Sydney Crosby and a power play goal for
the Penguins and Pittsburgh leads two to nothing
top of Charlie lingren this Puck hits the skate
of gensel and bounces right to Crosby Crosby's
looking for the deflection it doesn't come oh this
deflects off a Nick Jensen stick too as Crosby's
able to chip that over lingren the Penguins
two goals in this period one by Malin one by
Crosby that'll send it back but re D can look to
reset for Washington approaching the Midway point
of the game two nothing in favor of the Penguins
Malin and Crosby even heard that one before here's
a chance shot off the post back into this it's
Conor McMichael his shot beats jari brings off
the goal post as this snapshot is almost swing it
across now Carlson will run it from there trying
to go back door gensel to the slot Carlson from
M lets it go gensel on side of the net gobbled
up by Charlie lingin now he'll free it and kill
some more clock as the capital's clear [Applause]
there go the first 30 seconds what a luxury you
can put Eric Carlson out there on your first unit
then Chris L Tang on your second power play unit
here's gensel shoots in deep Carlson lets it Go
locked by Wilson gel fans on the passing attempt
Carlson comes over takes another hit from Wilson
gel tried to get it across son of a that they
score Sydney Crosby another Power Play goal and
it's three nothing Penguins he's now got four
shots here he's got a couple of goals as this
Puck bounces off ael's pass and goes right back
to Malin Crosby's in position he thinks that
first Puck's coming but he stays there and he
swats it at the net the one-time beats Charlie
lingren and geny malin's got three points Crosby's
got two goals this second period has been perfect
by pengin standards and it's three nothing in the
same season and it's not getting any easier Ottawa
and buffalo and probably Detroit are really going
to squeeze in close to the race this year here's
Rael try to whip W home and that is partially
blocked down for Washington here's raela Rock
great save by Charlie lingren Crosby got it
to rust TR to work it down low pop out here's
Joseph Let It Go rebound loose for Riley Smith
and he's taken down of the ice still no whistle
scramble forward in the crease and finally now
we get the whistle scoreless after one and after
Charlie lingren hangs tough here and still finds
himself trailing three to [Applause] nothing caps
look to head man here's Alexander oetkin on the
Breakaway oetkin stop there by Tristan jari really
nice headman play Here by Dylan stro sends oetkin
in from the blue line he wants to go five hole on
Tristan Jory one thing that goalies will look at
is that aitkin's probably not going to deep he's
going to shoot it with the way that he does shoot
the pock jari holds his ground and it's just able
to get the stick down as oie wants to go right
through the five hole face off at Center as we
open up period number three again Washington
with a power play for a minute and 15 that was
a pretty contentious neutral zone face off yes
how about just throw the puck down and let's get
going and now it's a Pittsburgh Power Play Already
leading three and up and Carson Little Feather it
across on his backand get gets the return feed
swings it for Malin that shot caught the pipe
look like farari got a piece with his skate and
then off the pipe much better here in game two
by a long shot Malin who had four shots on a
goal after two periods rifles his slapper past
Charlie lingren off the goal post as lingren as
he moves across he moves actually across into the
screen of farari who tries to make a p was look
to set things up in front Carter had a stick on
the ice and couldn't tap it home lank forces it
for rust loose puck in front Riley Smith is STO
by Charlie lingren what a great move by Smith
to Shield the Pucket lingren read it and made
an excellent right pad stop Riley Smith's on
the goal line look at him take the puck to his
forehand and by doing that he Shields Jensen
away from the puck so Jensen can poke check
him this is a great play he gets his backside out
into Dylan stro malins back checking headman pass
penguin shot the score Riley Smith for Pittsburgh
off a great back check by Getti Malin make it 4
nothing penguin neutral zone on Carlson to steal
the puck and right up the ice to Smith and because
lingren catches with his right hand this is the
top glove this is a shot Smith probably wouldn't
make as readily if the blocker was on that side
terrific start and goal real good four check power
play clicked solid win for the pens and that'll
do it horn sounds do fi for Spencer Carberry